y
[Música]
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski visitó las poblaciones cercanas
aquí para comprobar los horrores
causados por las tropas rusas occidente
denuncia crímenes de guerra mientras que
moscú dice que se trata de otra puesta
en escena
en francia se acorta la brecha entre los
candidatos de ultraderecha y el
presidente manuel macrón de cara a la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales aunque el mandatario
sigue liderando las encuestas sus
contrincantes conservadores suman un
mayor porcentaje de favorabilidad
con tiro al pulso en el senado
estadounidense sobre la nominación de
que tan brown jackson a la corte suprema
la votación en el comité judicial
terminó en empate y ahora el pleno
define el rumbo de su nominación como la
primera mujer afro en servir en el
máximo órgano judicial analizamos en
esta emisión
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en flash 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz es el día 40 de la invasión
rusa a ucrania y el presidente vladimir
putin enfrenta acusaciones de crímenes
de guerra tras los descubrimientos
hechos en una ciudad recuperada por el
ejército ucraniano butch a donde
denuncian haber hallado fosas comunes de
supuestos civiles asesinados rusia
insiste en que todo hace parte de un
montaje andrés granadillo nos cuenta más
el presidente ucraniano
visitó mucho y denunció que la cifra de
muertes puede ser mayor y
estos son crímenes de guerra y serán
reconocidos por el mundo como genocidio
ustedes están aquí pueden ver lo que
sucedió sabemos que miles de personas
fueron asesinadas y torturadas
desgarradas y violadas y asesinatos de
niños
el presidente de eeuu joe biden acusó de
nuevo a su homólogo ruso vladimir putin
de ser un criminal de guerra
ustedes recordarán que fui criticado por
llamar criminal de guerra a vladimir
putin bueno vi lo que pasó en ducha esto
lo justifica es un criminal de guerra
washington pedirá a la asamblea general
de la onu que suspenda a rusia del
consejo de derechos humanos por su parte
de los rusos por intermedio del ministro
de relaciones exteriores insisten en que
es según ellos un montaje de ucrania
el ejército ruso se retiró por completo
de esta ciudad el 30 de marzo el 31 de
marzo el alcalde de la ciudad de bullas
declaró solemnemente que todo estaba en
orden dos días después vimos cómo se
organizaba esta puesta en escena en la
calle y como ahora están tratando de
usarla con fines anti rusos
mientras que la organización human
rights watch investiga en el terreno los
posibles crímenes
debe ser había un cuerpo que estaba aquí
y estoy tratando de buscar cualquier
evidencia física de cómo fue asesinado
de donde fue asesinados y
lo que estamos viendo en el suelo aquí
son algunos casquillos de balas y
6.2
respuesta a alemania expulsará a 40
diplomáticos rusos de la embajada de
berlín francia tomará la misma medida
contra 35 funcionarios de la embajada de
rusia en territorio galo entre otros
vamos hasta alemania porque el gobierno
tomó el control temporal de la filial
alemana de la empresa de gas rusa
gazprom el objetivo según el ministro de
economía es asegurar el suministro de
energía en el país estoy en medio de las
preocupaciones por una eventual escasez
de hidrocarburos procedentes de rusia a
raíz de las sanciones impuestas a moscú
la medida se da luego de que gazprom
rusia abandonara su negocio en
territorio alemán sin ofrecer más
detalles
a más de un mes desde el inicio de la
guerra en ucrania miles de personas
siguen refugiándose en el metro de kiev
uno de los lugares más seguros de la
ciudad al haber sido diseñado y
construido justamente como refugio
frente a bombardeos durante las guerras
mundiales sus más de 60 kilómetros
cuentan con la infraestructura esencial
e incluso con agua potable allí los que
evitas han intentado formar una nueva
cotidianidad de vida subterránea manuel
acá no tiene la historia
los últimos meses del embarazo de anna
transcurren bajo las calles de kiev el
metro de la ciudad se ha convertido en
un segundo hogar para ella su esposo y
su madre entre los tres intentan forjar
una vida tranquila en medio del caos que
atraviesa su país que se extrae trato de
no estar nerviosa me besa ahora lo más
importante y trato de que nada le afecte
busco estar tranquila viendo series o
películas conversando con mi madre
manteniendo la calma con las pocas
asociaciones del iva como ellos miles de
personas trasladaron su vida del
subterráneo desde el inicio de la guerra
cuando el propio alcalde de la capital
llamó a la ciudadanía a refugiarse en la
red de metro diseñada en 1960 en medio
de la guerra fría es uno de los lugares
más seguros de la ciudad al ser pensada
para afrontar contextos bélicos el foso
tienes que matar volcán hay quienes que
metropolitan desde el primer día la
principal función del metro de kiev fue
refugiar a gente y en total todas las
estaciones acogieron a unas 15.000
personas en esta estación hubo dos mil
200 personas viviendo en los primeros
días
de tres líneas de metro 67 kilómetros y
52 estaciones ahora cumplen una función
muy diferente a la movilidad de la
capital hay los que evitas no sólo pasan
sus noches sino que intentan formar una
nueva cotidianidad bajo tierra incluso
con momentos de diversión como éste
pese a que el kremlin ha retirado buena
parte de las tropas que intentan cercar
la ciudad y asegura que concentra sus
ataques en el este del país unos 4000
que evitas siguen refugiados en el
subterráneo muchos afirman no confiar en
las intenciones rusas y temen que
continúen los bombardeos
faltan seis días para la primera vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales en
francia y el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón urgió a los ciudadanos a salir a
votar el próximo domingo 10 de abril a
medida que se estrecha la diferencia en
los sondeos entre él y la
ultraderechista marine lepén el
presidente manuel macrón sigue liderando
las encuestas con un 26.5 por ciento de
favorabilidad le sigue el epen con un 23
por ciento y jean-luc mélenchon con 17
por ciento a él le siguen otros
candidatos como valerie pécresse y eric
se mudó a pesar de que el mandatario
encabeza la lista el apoyo en conjunto
hacia los aspirantes conservadores es
mucho mayor
y de cara a la primera vuelta de las
elecciones en france 24 hemos preparado
una serie de reportajes sobre los
asuntos en juego la inmigración parecía
ser el centro de debate en la campaña
pero ahora está eclipsado por la guerra
en ucrania sin embargo no deja de ser
una de las prioridades ángela gutiérrez
nos cuenta que proponen los aspirantes
francia vive hoy una inmigración sin
precedentes actualmente hay 7 millones
de inmigrantes el 10,3 por ciento de la
población total la cifra más alta el
número y porcentaje de la población que
el país ha registrado que proponen los
candidatos para enfrentar este desafío
referéndum 10 de los 12 candidatos
quieren hacer esta consulta sobre los
temas clave del país incluida la
migración pero dos se focalizan en el
tema tanto marín depende el partido
reagrupación nacional como eric fémur
del partido la reconquista ambos de
extrema derecha proponen un referendo
para ponerle fin al reagrupamiento
familiar y al derecho europeo por encima
del francés además de endurecer el
acceso a la nacionalidad reformular el
control de las fronteras y la creación
por parte de ese muro del ministerio de
la re migración para expulsar a un
millón de cyrus derecho de asilo todos
los candidatos quieren garantizarlo pero
con ajustes el presidente candidato de
manuel macrón de la república en marcha
quiere facilitar la expulsión de las
personas a las que se les haya negado
asilo y mantener las cuotas de
inmigrantes una reforma en su mandato
que para muchos fue un giro a la derecha
de su política migratoria lepe en ese
muro y la candidata conservadora valérie
pécresse de los republicanos quieren que
todas las solicitudes se hagan desde el
exterior la expulsión de condenados
extranjeros 5 de los 12 candidatos
manifiestan en sus programas estar de
acuerdo con la expulsión de delincuentes
extranjeros la pnp cres macrón y se
murió este último propone expulsar
también a los fichados como radicales
islamistas lucha contra el islam radical
y el terrorismo macro mantiene la idea
del cierre de asociaciones y mezquitas
radicales y en firme la llamada ley
contra el separatismo aprobada en su
quinquenio la misma que quiere derogar
el candidato de izquierda jean luc
mélenchon de la francia insumisa por
considerarla anti republicana y tildada
por le ven como insuficiente
vivirá de raíz la práctica y la difusión
pública de la ideología islamista
quienes entran a francia y quienes no un
desafío en las propuestas de los
candidatos que tratan de responder a
este fenómeno migratorio al que ahora se
suma la ola de refugiados ucranianos
cambiamos de tema y hacemos un resumen
de las principales noticias sobre el
kobe 19 esta semana uruguay dice que
pondrá fin a la emergencia sanitaria
declarada hace dos años cuando se
detectaron los primeros casos del nuevo
coronavirus en el país uruguay es uno de
los menos golpeados por el virus en
américa latina que registra una de las
mayores tasas de vacunación
en su intento o en su intención por
recuperar el turismo cuba ya no exigirá
una prueba negativa de kobe 19 el
certificado de vacunación a los viajeros
que deseen ingresar a la isla la
decisión obedece en parte según las
autoridades a los niveles de
inmunización alcanzados o va a registrar
la tasa de vacunación más alta de
américa latina y el caribe con las
vacunas desarrolladas por su propia
comunidad siente
shanghai es extenderá el confinamiento
impuesto a sus 26 millones de habitantes
mientras analiza los resultados de las
pruebas realizadas en una masiva campaña
para contener el brote del cobi 19 la
metrópoli china podría enfrentar el peor
brote de coronavirus que ha habido desde
que empezó la pandemia
que pasamos a eeuu el senado continúa
definiendo la confirmación de que tan y
brawn jackson a la corte suprema de
justicia una votación en el comité
judicial resultó en un empate entre
demócratas y republicanos pero el
proceso logró pasar al pleno de la
cámara alta en la que se espera que
jackson sea confirmada como la primera
mujer afro en llegar hasta el máximo
órgano judicial para analizar este tema
saludamos al constitucionalista rafael
cox alomar quien nos acompaña desde
puerto rico señor cox bienvenido a
france 24 con o sin el apoyo de los
republicanos podríamos decir que la
confirmación de que tan ye brawn jackson
a la corte suprema es un hecho
pero buenas tardes gracias por la
invitación y tal parece que hay tres
senadores republicanos que van a
respaldar la nominación de la ues a
jackson
por consiguiente habrían de los 100
votos que hay en el senado habrían 53
votos para confirmar a la jueza jackson
ella va a necesitar a la mayoría de los
que estén presentes en el hemiciclo se
debe de esperar que todos los senadores
estén presentes y con los
demócratas más los votos de estos tres
republicanos que son emite romney de
yuta lisa murkowski de alaska y susan
collins de maine se espera de que la ues
a jackson sea confirmada en el hemiciclo
próximamente ahora es común que los
nominados a la corte suprema se
encuentren en un fuego cruzado entre
republicanos y demócratas porque este
proceso ha sido menos traumático que los
que se eligieron por ejemplo a los
conservadores predicaban o jamie con y
barrett
bueno era una circunstancia política un
poco distinta
había habido unos hallazgos preliminares
con respecto al juez cavanna
que creó una opinión pública negativa en
contra de esa nominación
en este momento también está bien
polarizada pero la jueza jackson tiene
un expediente limpio de polvo y paja no
tiene ningún señalamiento de ninguna
índole de ninguna naturaleza y la
división es una meramente política
y no sería la primera vez que una jueza
llega al supremo con una votación
dividida
lamentablemente en los últimos tiempos
ese ha sido el caso de muchas de estas
nominaciones el tribunal supremo de eeuu
ahora de qué manera puede cambiar la
corte suprema tras la llegada de jackson
pues sería la primera mujer afro sí pero
antes que ella ya se encontraba el
conservador clarence thomas que también
es una persona afro
bueno el primer juez negro al tribunal
supremo de eeuu eso se dio en
1967 verdad no es nada nuevo es ser
gutmar tal fue el primer juez negro
1967 nombrados por el presidente johnson
en este en esta ocasión en las cosas más
o menos se van a quedar igual porque
existe una mayoría de jueces
conservadores en ese tribunal que son de
6 a 36 jueces
denominados por presidentes republicanos
algunos de los cuales tienen una visión
bien conservadora y solamente quedarían
tres jueces más liberales que serían las
webs a jackson la jueza sotomayor que es
la primera jueza del supremo hispana y
la jueza elena kagan que fue nominada
por el presidente obama así que en
términos ideológicos el tribunal más o
menos quedaría en una configuración muy
parecida a la que hay en este momento
pues bien era rafael cox alomar
constitucionalista muchas gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en france24 y empezó
en florida el juicio contra nicolás cruz
por la masacre en la escuela de park
lane en febrero de 2018 en octubre de
2021 el joven de 23 años se declaró
culpable de asesinar a 17 personas por
lo que el jurado solamente decidirá si
recibe la pena de muerte o cadena
perpetua los padres y familias de las
víctimas se han manifestado a favor de
que cruz reciba la pena de muerte
en twitter tiene un nuevo accionista y
es nada más y nada menos que el
multimillonario y la mosca el director
de tesla reveló que ya tiene el 9,2 por
ciento de las acciones de la compañía
tecnológica y que las compró por casi
tres mil millones de dólares ahora nadie
tiene más porcentaje de la empresa que
él la compra llegará luego de que moscú
dijera que tenía pensado crear una nueva
plataforma de redes sociales y
cuestionará twitter por su compromiso
con la libertad de expresión
así despedimos este informativo gracias
por acompañarnos
[Música]